[Musique]
le monde selon ma mobylette en australie
un pays grand comme une douzaine de fois
la france avec une population
équivalente à celle de paris et sa
banlieue le principe c'est trouver une
mobylette et partir visiter le pays avec
ça risque de pas être une chose facile
vu qu'ici la voiture est reine des
distances sont énormes et que la
mobylette n'est sûrement pas le moyen de
transport privilégié des habitants mais
je crains pas le défi je vais aller
chercher et voir ce que je peux trouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas trouvé il n'y a pas de mobile
est en australie c'est aussi simple que
ça donc ça sert à rien de chercher n'y a
pas de mobile est donc j'ai trouvé un
magasin tu fais des scooters en général
c'est plutôt de la location c'est pour
des gens qui veulent juste aller à la
plage pas pour des grosses distance et
c'est avec ce scooter 50 centimètres
cubes que je me prépare à faire un
voyage de plus de 2000 kilomètres vous
pensez que je peux aller jusqu'à broom
avec sa wii mais avec une seconde voire
hier
qu'en fait il freine un peu pour un fou
parce que je pense qu'il n'y a jamais un
mec qui a acheté un scooter ici pour
aller jusqu'à blum c'est le meilleur
moyen mais ça va être un très long
voyage
c'est certes un bon bras souhaitez moi
bonne chance
allez bonne chance faites un bon voyage
oui j'espère
je vous passer un coup de fil oui donnez
moi un coup de fil si vous avez le
moindre problème
et surtout si je réussis je vous
téléphone oui donnez moi un coup de fil
et envoyez moi une carte postale de
monde
bon allez
soyez plus d'un poil ça a
quel bruit on sent on sent la grosse
image
autant
voyage merci mademoiselle bas y
aller
[Musique]
allô bonjour je suis ici dans un magasin
qui est typique typiquement australien
où on trouve tout ce qu'il faut pour
aller dans le bush australien boat
australienne le chapeau australien
typique la moustiquaire intégré au
chapeau est forcément
le slip kangourou
vous prenez cette tante yacine merci
on vous dit bonjour ici
non ça veut dire bonjour non mais qui
dit ça c'est dans le bush les gars
parlent comme ça alors dites moi si je
le fais bien que oui
non mais sérieusement je peux dire ça ou
c'est une blague non mais ils vont tous
se de moi quand je vais faire ça
bon allez comme on dit ici pas de
problème tout va bien
merci beaucoup merci que ça match ban
allez c'est parti
je sais pas si c'est très sérieuse que
je suis en train de faire
d'envisager un voyage en australie
avec son deux roues
les nas porte bagages et ben je crois
que c'est comme ça je vais commencer
aller avant le grand ouest
[Musique]
direction plein nord en longeant la côte
ouest tout ce qu'on voit en général
c'est ce qui se passe sur la côte est et
comme j'aime pas faire comme tout le
monde je suis parti à l'ouest
alors un vrai problème et mon problème
il s'appelle works rain crooked rain
c'est le train de la route est en fait
il n'y a pas de bande d'arrêt d'urgence
et quand ils arrivent ils ont parfois
quatre morts qu'ils font je sais pas
parce que 100 mètres de long
et il m'apporte complètement avec quand
je les vois dans le rétroviseur est
obligé de me mettre son côté m'arrêter
complètement
voilà et ça c'est pas possible c'est
juste juste au dessus donc je vais aller
jusqu'à dire halton qui est là et puis
après je vais voir mais je pense qu il
va falloir que je fasse certains
tronçons on stoppe et puis je mettrai le
scooter à l'arrière ou dans un camion
dans un 4 4
[Musique]
allô bonjour comment ça gueule
bon burger bon burger australien
enyama de viande de kangourou dans vos
burger rien d'exotique comme viande nous
on préfère les moutons qu'on élève nous
mêmes non sérieusement ça serait super
si je pouvais mettre mon scooter à
l'arrière de votre morgue parce qu'ici
les distances sont vraiment trop longue
alors à nous deux ça serait facile de
soulever mon scooter et de l'embarqué
dans votre remorque
manger lors de rigueur et puis après je
fais je vais embarquer mon scooter dans
dans leurs remorques
pour faire vite le mieux c'est que tu
restais assise sur ton scooter dans la
remorque arrêtez de vous de moi
si je te jure tu pourras directement
sauter avec son scooter en marche quand
on te débarquant
génial ok
ok
à
khales de 10 ouais
bon peut-être que le mieux ça serait de
cure est assis sur la selle par un
voyage ouais ouais bien sûr
[Musique]
les mecs d utiliser ce type de deux
roues pour faire le tri des moutons
pas vraiment j'imagine knot
away
ils disent que leurs moutons serait plus
gros déjà que le scooter dont il utilise
pas ça dit on utilise des motos
sérieuses quoi débattre est
impeccable voilà
comment rater quelques centaines de
kilomètres c'est mouillé ou quoi
wall e mais si
bordeaux
est alors les gars vous avez un pare
choc devant le radiateur de votre 4 4
mais je vois pas de grille de protection
sur le pare brise
en deux
1 de windows kane a
cogné quelques animaux sauvages sur les
routes de temps en temps ça arrive quoi
les kangourous principalement des
kangourous des émeus et pas mal de
chèvre
[Musique]
bon c'est là on va se quitter dites vous
travaillez vraiment au milieu de nulle
part
et merci beaucoup pour le transport
tu peux nous filer quelques dollars en
bois à ta santé
[Musique]
bon ok marrant ton casque bien c'est mon
casque porte-bonheur dialogue
mais qu'est ce qui t'es arrivé c'est
quoi se trouve c'est le soleil qui rend
fou ici en fait c'est ce petit mariole
qui m'a tiré dessus a tiré dessus
allez merci beaucoup à l'est soit
prudent jusqu'à rom
et voilà 200 km de gratter
parlons de la météo un peu bleu bleu
bleu bleu vraiment roulant quand les
coups de chaleur
tu l'auras diamant ce pas un peu trop
j'avance pas je dois faire du scandale
y'a pas et à travers
l'océan indien sont nos à 27 degrés
c'est le moment d'aller faire une petite
baignade pour moi
il y apparaît utile ici un peu plus loin
une attraction tout à fait particulière
c'est à dire que c'est le l'endroit où
il ya des dauphins qui viennent tout
près du rivage je crois que les gens et
nourrissent c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'attendais à un truc un peu plus un
peu plus sauvage bon j'ai pas perdu au
change il faut savoir que y'a rien
d'exceptionnel est sur une plage comme
ça parce que la côte ouest de
l'australie le sud le nord sont des
milliers et des milliers
des milliers de kilomètres de plages
strictement déserte
j'ai ma passion née si on est 20 sur la
plage en fait
[Musique]
et
l'agent parfaire mon bronzage
sauvage
mobylette
la tête au bo
limité à 80 on pense aux copains
venus
50 le vêtement
[Musique]
il est parfait
juste
celle sur les lieux
[Musique]
les deux nuits milieu du désert
est-ce que c'est là mon emplacement
c'est ça le truc je suis un peu habitué
aux tentes qu'on jette en l'air et qui
s'ouvrent toutes seules ça c'est
vraiment à l'ancienne ça
[Applaudissements]
va ça va bien passer la nuit au camping
oui exactement là où planter votre tente
et si oui à je croyais que c'était mon
emplacement et c'est l'emplacement 45
alors je pensais que c'était le 42e
c'est le
45t de ferme aventuriers je pense que
j'ai mieux joué un bungalow
[Musique]
et un garde-côte là bas
ils sont bien bien organisés les touts
les les campings en australie
il ya un poste de garde côtes là
je suis allé voir comment
l'australie est protégé
bonjour bonjour quand vous allez vous
viendrez vous
quel est votre nom françois
mobile uk ravi de vous connaissez vite
ravi de vous rencontrer qu'est ce que
c'est vous êtes un garde-côte coast
guard je suis un gars de coûts d'une
terre je poursuis les migrants illégaux
et trafiquants prod les terroristes les
pirlo coraux les pêcheurs illégaux vega
vous savez on a des milliers de
kilomètres de plage isolée y a personne
ici c'est facile de débarquer non mais
vous n'avez pas d'armes pouvant
intervenir
sicile voilà mon arme
[Rires]
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce mobile homes
vivait là c'est là où vous dormez rien
de spécial à l'intérieur fait si mais je
peux pas vous en parler vous êtes un
garçon très secret il ya quelques
équipements de surveillance un peu
particulier mais jean les équipements
spéciaux vous êtes une sorte de james
bond en fait ouais c'est ça mais vous
avez rase pas là bas
[Rires]
après une rude journée patrouille c'est
agréable se relaxer dans son spa avec
une bouteille de champagne à la main
mais est-ce que ça va bien dans votre
tête pas de problème tout va bien
parfois je m'inquiète aussi
parfois j'ai envie de buman
on va aller faire une petite patrouille
j'espère qu'on va pas croisé terroriste
avec secret donc pour aller poursuivre
longtemps il fait du 110 km h oui mais
vous allez me mets moi
ok captain
je veux un seuil
ce mec est taré
[Musique]
mais alors est ouest vous suit
qu'athènes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans un sens je vois rien rien d'anormal
tout se passe bien
et je patine mois
canal m attendez moi
je peux pas aller plus loin moi j'ai pas
le bon matériel pour vous suivre ouais
votre ou à rire sans sable ouais il faut
j'ai bon scout il patine trop là je suis
pas la hauteur pour faire une patrouille
la hongrie toutes ces villages et sous
votre surveillance il a 300 et
340 km de plage
pour lui yunus est l'homme le même
chanceux du monde
avec mon scooter ça va pas être possible
et pour être votre assistance et quand
vous voulez capitaine à vous êtes le
bienvenu on a besoin de volontaires bâti
comme je peux venir ici est surveillé
rico avec this way mais attention c'est
du sérieux peut te faire tirer dessus
bien sûr les terroristes qui n'hésite
pas enfin bill il n'y a pas de
terroristes y
savelli à 37 mille kilomètres de côtes
surveiller on peut faire ce qu'on veut
effectivement si un bateau arrivé ici
personne ne le remarque c'est assez
juste des gens du point mais le
capitaine et l'a4 capitaine est aux
aguets merci beaucoup capitaine je peux
pas aller plus loin donc le mieux c'est
de m'arrêter ici
[Musique]
cd type dans le genre de captain bill
que j'ai envie de rencontrer ici en
western australia mais pour ça il faut
que je sorte de l'autoroute à moi la
piste elle est ce qu'au fond de bouche
[Musique]
ceddat tôle ondulée et auquel se
souvenir que j'ai acheté nous coûtera
moins cher que j'ai trouvée et j'espère
que je suis pas en train de démonter
roulant les boulons a été bien serré
elle compliquée
[Musique]
oui
je vais faire le candidat mitterrand
était un type qui a une pelle à bâle est
en train de nettoyer le désert des
cannes à aller boire et se fait ce
monsieur
[Musique]
et
c'est là moi je ramasse des morceaux de
verre les restes de canettes de bière et
toutes ces saletés que les gens
balancent sur la piste
vous ramasser des ordures ouais tous ces
détritus ah je pensais que vous
ramassiers des choses particulières
comme des plantes rares ou vous savez
peut-être de l'or comme on est en
australie
mais non c'est pas l'or qui vous
intéressent vous voyez cette zone
sauvage là-bas en face c'est superbe
derrière vous aussi moi j'ai passé
plusieurs mois à la nettoyer j'ai ramené
près de 500 sacs poubelles
vous avez nettoyer toute cette zone
jusqu'à la colline là bas
mais c'est insensé stop arrêtez de faire
ça non mais arrêtez vous n'avez tout de
même pas tout nettoyer jusqu'à la
colline d'abord je sale pour ramasser
les bouteilles de bière les canettes et
tous les objets dégoûtant comme le
papier toilette ou voyez le genre bref
tout ce que je ne veux pas toucher mais
pour les petits morceaux de verre il
faut utiliser ses doigts car c'est trop
petit
regardez ça tu veux mais regardez c'est
pas mieux comme ça tout beau tout propre
ça de la lure c'est mieux non depuis
combien de temps vous faites ça ça fait
près de deux ans deux ans et il ya un
autre type qui fait la même chose que
moi du côté de l'océan près des plages
maintenant on est deux dans le coin et
vous vous êtes de france
oui je suis français et je traverse
l'australie de l'ouest avec ce petit
scooter
j'ai commencé avec ce scout et je
terminerai le voyage avec nous et si
j'ai de la chance au revoir et bonne
chance génial
il ya des gens qui sont motivés mais
c'est bien c'est très très bien
petit
d'abord dit qu'ils nettoient
bonjour non au revoir au revoir comme en
rêvent même si je peux me permettre de
vous donner un petit conseil vous
devriez passer un peu moins de temps à
nettoyer le désert et réaliser un petit
peu votre français
pensent qu'il a fait quelque chose de
pas bien dans sa vie il doit se faire
pardonner c'est pas possible on nettoyé
le désert là
enfin bon
[Musique]
allez faut pas traîner on m'a dit qu'à
50 km d'ici en plein désert il y avait
une ferme d'élevage de moutons j'ai
téléphoné aux fermiers l'accueil des
routards comme moi pour la nuit il est
très sympa j'y vais je fonce alex cole
[Musique]
hambourg est jeune avec l'écran groupe a
retrouvé
hier
j'arrive à la station dolois ma60 ici le
fameux moutons australien
à
l'onu il ya des munchies
je
l'ambiance
ah le bonheur
ah c'est pas vrai
je bouge plus je reste là
le rêve le rêve absolu
à
mon avis je peux laisser la clé sur
scooter
aucun problème
il ya quelqu'un avait ça doit être
ça doit être le boss
la petite famille
ça va ça va bien que la
petite famille oui voici sacha eva et
moland
ravi de rencontrer françois moi c'est
marty hume a ravi de voir encore très
marqué ça me fait plaisir descendez les
enfants
[Applaudissements]
alors tu viens juste d'arriver ah ouais
je viens de débarquer là et tu voyages
en scooter sur un scooter
c'est le petit dernier
bonsoir merci de m'accueillir moi c'est
françois
oui eh bien
tu la payes et françois sûrement trop
cher je les payais mille dollars
mais c'est ok j'ai pris le moins cher du
magasin d'ici mais c'est que de la
camelote d'ipad enfin la gamme
pour la ville pour aller à la plage
c'est bien pour le désert ses papiers
ouais c'est ça
le veulent bien
j'adorerais
aller bonne chance pour ton voyage et
santé
c'est un endroit magnifique pour
travailler martin ou alors mais
peut-être que c'est trop dur pour
travailler parce que c'est trop beau
elle a juste envie de rien faire et
profiter de ce paysage magnifique wii en
un sens j'ai une chance incroyable mais
je suis souvent débordés c'est très dur
car nous sommes trois pour exploiter un
domaine large de 40 km 150 fiton domaine
s'étend sur 50 km de côtes
juste chez toi
ici oui c'est l'un des réservoirs d'eau
potable installé sur la ferme c'est de
l'eau salée qui vient de l'océan
lé dessaliniser par 7 pompes en est en
panne il doit y avoir des animaux morts
qui bouchent le fond du puits
parce que l'eau c'est capital pour vous
en australie et non c'est un problème
très grave depuis quelques années mais
sécheresses à répétition ça nous rend
malades en ce moment les problèmes d'eau
c'est ton travail principal
surtout maintenant on l'était quand il
ya un petit orage c'est génial ça
humidifie les terres
mais là depuis trois mois on n'a pas eu
une seule inverse les marques sont à sec
et on risque de mourir
m'a proposé un truc mais je pas sûr d'y
aller moi aussi cette descente dans le
puits parce que je crois qu'il ya des
oiseaux morts il faut les retirer tu vas
descendre dans le puits oui c'est sûr de
faire ça les chiots de dollars oui je
les fais déjà plusieurs fois tu l'as
fait combien de fois déjà 3 4 x 7
ils veulent qu'on tient à la courte
paille celui qui va descendre
études il ya des serpents poussée des
goûts et parfois mélangées aux eaux mort
mais j'en vois pas là
il était près
bien non je ne dis pas à mon pote tu te
fais confiance qu'on soit il veut pas
que je disais à son copain qui
travaillent avec lui qu'il est en train
de mettre des oiseaux morts dans le dans
le la gourde qu'ils utilisent pour boire
de l'eau fraîche je te fais confiance il
sera pas content
marramao marty cette attention françois
non non c'est fini c'est tout propre en
bas
mon dieu ça devient plus dure avec l'âge
les coûts de marquer quand tu seras
plusieurs s'il te plaît dis moi que tu
feras plus ça non 10h à l'océan indien
mais langouste les poissons la vie dure
marty
ouais du poisson
c'est que les gens vont être jaloux de
voir ton petit paradis comme ça
ok
pour rihanna tu es sur le canal
écoute on a fini le travail avec
françois on va voir les enfants à
l'école elles sont toujours là
tu appelles qui ont une maîtresse
d'école l'école principale est à 300 km
cette insolence elle enseigne à tes
enfants ici à la ferme
alors ça c'est les cordes des schistes
de secours
c'est l'école primaire si marty
alo'o la maîtresse
bonjour les enfants
[Musique]
alors les filles ça va gueuler vous
allez à l'école où vous regardez la télé
c'est un programme éducatif les enfants
on limite la salle de classe oui désolé
ce n'est pas vrai mais c'est le dernier
jour de classe aujourd'hui c'est le
dernier jour de l'année scolaire oui ces
derniers jours d'école et on répète
notre spectacle de fin d'année c'est la
fête
voilà le dernier dessin de sacha sur le
thème ou squelette humain tu me montres
c'est lui et lui c'est une idée va ça
c'est ton travail ici maîtresse d'école
je suis de sydney je voulais enseigner
dans un endroit isolé ça fait un an que
je suis ici je reçois par internet les
instructions de leur maîtresse basée en
ville on travaille ensemble et je
retourne par internet et de voir une
fois terminée c'est leur maîtresse de la
ville qui les notes
[Musique]
ban
c'est une très bonne chanson ça je
n'écoute pas
[Musique]
bravo bien chanter les enfants bravo les
enfants cette chanson sur les eaux fait
partie du spectacle qu'elles vont
bientôt jouer avec leurs camarades en
ville alors comment les trouvez votre
maîtresse est ce que c'est une bonne
maîtresse oui oui oui c'est sûr alors
vous le montrez le reste de votre école
oui avec plaisir
allez je veux tout voir ou bien le
tableau je vais écrire ça
[Musique]
chat ok je vais écrire mon nom
maintenant
ok
il écrit bien
oui c'est quand m
là c'est le csb ça n'existe pas pour nom
qui
fera office et françois françois
françois kahn à gauche peut rester
encore un peu si ce n'était pas le
dernier jour de l'année car je serais
bien resté avec vous pour apprendre
encore quelques leçons m'amuser
m'asseoir avec nous et jouer avec des
dinosaures oui sacha temps de
reconstituer le squelette de dinosaure
avec les eaux d'un mouton elle étudie le
t-rex est-ce que tu as trouvé combien il
fallait placer deux vertèbres pour faire
son coup les deux premières d'hôtel
grosse pour supporter la tête
les eaux peu plus mince
je dois dire que je m'attendais pas à
trouver jeune femme élégante comme vous
en arrivant ici
je pensais qu'on débarque on dans une
ferme en plein désert j'allais tomber
sur des vieux fermier australien tout
poussiéreux
et je tombe sur une jeune femme très
élégante et sophistiquée
merci
c'est assez surprenant bons rails à la
merci pour l'accueil les enfants au
revoir à bientôt
aller aux chaînes
où je vais dormir
quel accueil
à bien
c'est lui
[Musique]
et le 2
là
matt damon
c'est maintenant que ça devient plus
parce que c'est à cette heure ci que les
kangourous short
endroit
gros kangourou
ce cadeau m dos et mon scooter qui a pas
photo
rimbaud go
[Musique]
bon pour ce soir c'est loupé rouler avec
des camions la nuit c'est carrément pas
possible il ya longtemps que je devrais
être peinard à l'abri dans ma chambre de
motel c'est la vie allez courage encore
50 bornes et de dos
[Musique]
[Rires]
cocotiers plages dorées le paradis quoi
y'a juste de temps en temps un petit
problème les crocodiles de mer ils
s'aiment bien se balader le long des
côtes surtout plus on monte vers le nord
ya un type qui les connaît très bien
plutôt que de les tuer il a décidé de
les capturer c'est une légende
australienne il s'appelle mal comme
douglas et moi j'ai rendez vous avec lui
bonjour mal comme meilleur joueur
autonome comment ça va bien bien review
vous êtes de paris ouais de france
vous savez j'ai beaucoup de contacts
professionnels avec la france et parier
tous les crocodiles que vous allez voir
ici terminant sac à main
on a les meilleurs peau du monde
beaucoup de gens viennent de france pour
m'acheter mes pots
descente clé bah
moi je vous propose de faire sortir un
crocodile je lance un appât ladsous sous
les eaux il ya un très gros au coni le
dr des chances qui sortent
si vous êtes prêts je vais vous montrer
le crocodile vous êtes sûr c'est une
bonne idée d'aller avec vous ou alors
c'est quelque chose de complètement
dingue allez viens tu veux avoir le choc
de tv voir un énorme crocodile et c'est
pas tous les jours je suis les regarde
bon je reste ici est bien derrière il y
aura pas de danger
les avances
n'ai pas peur
reste juste en arrière de moi toi pas
nerveux
dans l'eau là-bas à se rapprocher il
bouge bien vite
aller bien
il affirme avoir allez françois
rapproche toi de moi
felicia bon
maintenant ce qu'il fait
allez recul en arrière retourne dans
l'eau
dès qu'ils sortent de son oeuf il veut
mordre tout ce qu'il veut faire pour
défendre son territoire c'est tout tu et
ça dure depuis deux cent millions
d'années est lâché la balle si vite
qu'elle m'a frappé le visage au point de
mes tours dire
maintenant je me méfie quand il parle
allez je te montre des plus petits
qu'est ce que vous cherchez la
les bonzes de la ferme
ce sont des futurs crocodiles ont été
pondus nom de termes il ya trente deux
jours et tu vois cette marque sombre là
au milieu ça veut dire qu'il est un bébé
crocodile en gestation ça a marché
ils vont finir en sac à main sur le
marché français
tient lui aussi aura besoin d'une copine
bret
et bien par la
calmer
et se casse pas trop les dents sur la
ferraille
si jeune
tu comprendras dans tes mains
attention sert le bien par le coup car
la mâchoire et déjà vos raquettes
arular ouhlala
[Musique]
c'est bizarre
les gens ne nous croient pas quand on
leur dit il y a un réel danger celui
dans les estuaires et les longues robes
des baigneurs se font avoir chaque année
même un petit crocodile bébés parfois
rien qu'avec la force de sa mâchoire il
vous prend de vous entraîner sous l'eau
et vous noie au crocodile marin sont
capables de nager de 1000 kilomètres
dans l'océan seul à attendre leurs trois
mâts fascinant
bon bon en tout cas merci beaucoup mal
comme pour la visite continue bien ta
route je sais que vous êtes un homme
très occupé alors merci pour le temps
passé avec moi et à bientôt
[Rires]
bah je sais pas comment on sort de cette
ville
c'est pas que je me plaisent pas mais
bon
comme on dit c'est pas le tout
mais j'aime la route à faire c'est le
cas de le dire
[Musique]
il ya un retrait n'a arrêté sur le bord
de la route je vais tenter ma chance et
essayer de faire embarquer le scooter
quelques kilomètres de prix c'est
toujours ça de gagné
bonjour vous avez un problème non juste
une panne d'essence ça arrive souvent ce
genre de pannes c'est la faute j'ai pas
l'habitude du camion bon bah tant mieux
je me suis aussi avoir pas la distance
mais j'ai des garanties cap qui arrive
et dit moi il y aurait pas moyen de
mettre mon scooter à l'arrière votre
camion un scooter ah non là sur le
camion c'est pas possible les sur le
pick up qui arrive oui mais voilà
parfois
[Applaudissements]
salut marque alors qu'est ce que t'as
foutu t'es fait avoir comme un bleu
ouais bon on peut filer un coup de main
ces petits français ok dit moi messieurs
donc c'est possible de mettre deux
scooters à l'arrière et puis moi
j'embarque avec le chauffeur parfait
proposer le scooter
camions et surtout comme ça je gagne du
temps et des kilomètres
j'arrive
il est trop long ce train
et encore dés attendez je vais grimper
là haut
bon ok
allez on vous suit
larbin
nous apprenions va
tout roule avec lui un ouais je grimpe
en haut et on vous suit
mon scooter est loin maintenant oui mais
t'inquiète pas tu vas le récupérer un
peu embrouillé oui je sais enfin
j'espère vous n'avez pas trop de
problèmes avec les animaux sauvages qui
traversent la route dans le jour ça va
encore
et la nuit oui là faut vraiment faire
attention les kangourous les émeut en
cas de choc ça rebondit à ils
rebondissent le gros problème c'est les
vaches
quand ça cogne ça casse
il a tout ce qu'il faut
marge si je tiens le volant pendant
juste cinq secondes je pourrais dire
j'ai conduit un camion en australie je
t'en prie ça y est j'ai conduit un
camion d'australie
à la bonne opération
il est où mon scooter aller là bas
[Applaudissements]
ok enfin que sans merci les gars vous
m'avez vraiment bien dépanner mais les
gones
[Musique]
allez j'y suis presque dernière ligne
droite direction broom
[Musique]
je pense que je suis le premier rang
m'avoir fait sa demi l'attend
bref le menthol et bosselée fin du
périple j'arrive à blood
c'est bientôt le monde il sa gomme pour
un mec qui se baladant d'euros à
bourbourg
[Musique]
c'est ici que se termine donc mon
périple dans l'ouest australien dans ce
qu'aravane parc à blum il se trouve que
c'est un endroit intéressant parce qu'il
est assez représentatif de l'australie
que j'ai visité il ya beaucoup de gens
qui habitent ici à l'année certains sont
des saisonniers il s'habille dans les
caravanes ils vont travailler pour la
journée là il ya personne parce que tout
le monde est parti travailler
il fait déjà très chaud ce matin
c'est le début de l'été ici mais c'est
aussi bientôt noël et je trouve ça assez
drôle parce qu'il ya quelqu'un mes
voisins derrière camille un petit sapin
de noël avec les boules et les
guirlandes
je suis votre voisin alors j'ai vu votre
arbre de noël alors il est bon on n'est
ce pas c'est vous qui l'avez fait oui je
les fais chaque année j'en fais un
j'adore sa rentrée oui oui je vous en
prie faites pas attention au foutoir
vraiment j'adore la période oui c'est
une belle période mais vous savez
bizarre c'est vraiment étrange pour
quelqu'un comme moi de voir un arbre de
noël ici quand il fait plus 38 degrés à
l'ombre et habiter ici à l'aller oui ça
fait plus de quatre ans que je suis
arrivé ici à brou pour trouver du boulot
on travaille dans une imprimerie mais
mon salaire ne me permet pas de louer un
appartement vide encore moins d'acheter
une maison même en périphérie c'est trop
cher hors de prix pour un salaire
d'ouvrier alors pour les gars comme moi
la seule solution c'est de venir ici et
de louer à l'année des caravane au
camping
et chaque année quand même vous prenez
le temps de faire un arbre de noël ou le
c'est une tradition les gens autour
adorent ils viennent passer le réveillon
avec moi autour du sapin nous les
célibataires on se sent moins seul comme
ça alors un simple passant pourquoi pas
comme je ne serais pas là à noël pour le
fêter avec vous j'ai un petit cadeau
pour vous petite surprise un petit
cadeau pour moi vraiment oui je sais que
vous aimez noël alors j'ai pensé à vous
bah c'est sûr j'adore noël donc je pense
que j'ai un très bon cadeau pour vous
est-ce que je vais le chercher oui mais
s'ils ramènent le alors j'y vais
c'est parfait ça mon type il adore noël
j'ai un bon cadeau pour lui
qu'est ce que vous en pensez quoi
ouais
joyeux noël c'est une blague
non c'est pas vrai est ce qu'il te
convient non fantastique
joyeux noël
c'est pas une blague ouais c'est bien
comme ça tu peux aller se balader
dans le caravan part peut-être pour
aller au boulot ah c'est super pour boom
non c'est pas possible je ne crois pas
tu sais quoi mine de rien ce scooter a
traversé tout l'ouest de l'australie
marche très très bien j'ai pas eu le
moindre problème avec
non tu te fous de moi c'est pas vrai
génial il est bien content et pourtant
ce cadeau sa voix
à tout doucement bon bah je vais y aller
la rampe petit aller-retour pour voir
avec mon oeil
[Musique]
alors comment ça marche via un
fantastique
est ce que tu vas faire avec vraiment
servir pour aller bosser c'est moins
cher que d'utiliser sa voiture
très bon ouais c'est beaucoup plus
économique que d'aller en ville avec sa
voiture ah oui c'est moins cher qu'en
voiture c'est sûr ah c'est tellement
bien d'avoir ce compteur quand il fait
chaud dans à payer comme ça
c'est mieux que de rester collé sur son
siège de voiture
a bien mec gore et vous merci les gars
génial
il a un cadeau de noël votre poison
lachance toi c'est bon non
c'est un mois françois vient de me
l'offrir en cadeau de noël
mais sincèrement merci sais rien allez
tu t'achètes un casque je veux pas tu es
des problèmes avec la police à cause de
moi et puis je voyais au noël à vous
tous ok promis à toi aussi et beau
retour en france portez vous bien ouais
bah et françois
hallé fin du voyage dernière étape
traditionnelle le pub pour fêter ça
c'est incroyable pour moi je viens au
pub en australie et je découvre des
cheveux attachés devant l'entrée comme
au temps du far west ben ça fait partie
de nos traditions nous on aime bien
alors après le boulot on vient à cheval
salir prenez un petit clown c'est de la
barrière
c'est calme ce soir ouais les gars se
concentre sur le concours de billard de
ce sport
concours de billard je vais peut-être
essayer de jouer aussi
[Musique]
bien joué
guay belle partie merci mais tu me
donnes une bière et c'est le jeu pas de
problème je vais la payer la bière en
tout cas merci pour
ça m'a fait plaisir merci encore pour
des parties intimes bien merci vous
coûte inquiète pas toi aussi renversé ya
bientôt un sou